[Music]
hello everyone
uh in the previous two videos we had
discussed a couple of problems
related to the circular plate but
in today's video what i want to do is
go back to the general formulation
especially focusing on the boundary
condition
where we had obtained a term like this
so we had obtained those either or
statements and we had obtained
a term like this
one of the boundary conditions
had gotten expressed in this fashion
that either q n plus del m n s
del s is equal to 0 or something
something
and we had another statement also
now uh what we what we usually say
is that this particular combination qn
plus
del m s del s that is the
effective shear so this is the
q effective now
it is one thing to call it something uh
but it is completely another and
certainly more challenging
to actually interpret this term as an
effective shear so the question that we
want to answer today
is why this particular combination or
why this particular expression
is called the effective shear and please
note that
this is uh this is not a trivial
question
and uh people who had first developed
these theories
they had quite a challenging time uh
coming uh coming to a proper
interpretation of this it was
it was not done immediately okay so
uh i mean once once it was done it it i
mean
everything was clear so uh let's let's
try to
uh discuss this in as clear a way as
possible so first of all what we'll do
is we'll just
uh recap for our own benefit uh the unit
of this
q n so please note that
this q n that is uh
basically this
okay so this is sigma nz integrated over
the entire height
of the plate now you may note
that sigma nz that is a
shear stress and the unit of this
is of course newton per meter square and
when
integrated over the height it basically
becomes this entire integration
becomes newton per meter so this thing
has the unit of newton per meter
so even though we we say that this is
like a shear
but this is actually the shear per unit
length it is very very important to note
similarly for the mns
you please note that
this is
basically arising
in this fashion
now in the previous lectures i had not
explicitly written down these
expressions
because if you remember or if you just
go back to those previous videos
you will note that this m n is it was
written as a certain combination
of the the moment components
uh in the x y coordinate system we had
just
uh obtained this m s through
transformation
but we had not explicitly written down
this particular expression
but uh this is what it is going to be in
exactly the same fashion
that you are going to obtain the
expressions
uh we have in fact written down those
things m x y
uh m x m y okay so
uh so mx was sigma xxz dz
integration from minus h by 2 to h by 2
m y was similarly based on sigma yy
and mxy was based on sigma xy
in a similar fashion this mns is now
based on this
shear stress sigma ns
now just like we were concerned with the
unit of this
let us check this unit here also this is
newton per meter square here
there is a meter here there is a meter
here so overall
what we are going to obtain is this as
newton
this has the unit of newton all right
now before we can actually go into a
full-fledged interpretation of this
it is important to to really
understand what these expressions
really are uh in a more graphic
or visual sense so uh if we
if we reconsider our plate
if we reconsider our plate which was
something like this
and let us exaggerate the thickness
please note that if it is
really this thick then
uh
if it is really this thick then
the classical plate theory is really not
valid
okay
and the classical plate is really not
valid so uh
but but this is just like a a zoomed in
view
uh where you can imagine that
thickness has been zoomed in only okay
so it's just like a vertical zoom
anyway uh
so we had our x-axis like this
our y-axis like this
and our set in this vertically downward
fashion this is very important to recap
furthermore we had also noted
that if you look at the ns coordinate
system
our n would be like this and the s would
be like this
okay now based on this
uh these orientations of the x y z
axis as well as the n s axis let us
look at the interpretation of this by
isolating
uh
a little element out of here okay
we isolate a little element out of here
we focus on here
so this is the element that we can want
to focus on
here
we have our sigma nn
in this fashion
this is sigma
ns and
the z is still pointed downward
now you please note that
because our qn
is directly based on this sigma
nz so you can also understand that the
sigma nz
here will be in this fashion
this is our sigma nz so the qn
will be having the same orientation as
this sigma nz which means that the qn
will be pointed downward okay this is
very very
important to note and remember so our qn
it'll be like this next what about the
mns well you see
if i if i really make this somewhat
larger
let's make this even larger
let us say that this is the midpoint or
the mid mid mid plane
and our sigma ns
is in this fashion
now this sigma n is for the definition
of m ns
it has the moment arm z
which means that we have to consider
this kind of a moment arm which means
that in order to to
to represent or to to determine the
orientation of this
we have to turn in this sense
okay with this clockwise sense
well if it is in this clockwise sense
that is
generating this mns so overall what is
going to happen
is that the m s is going to be
in this fashion
okay so if you curl your fingers around
this
then uh the curl your fingers of your
right hand around this
then your thumb would be pointing into
this plane
okay it would be pointing opposite to
the uh to the orientation
of the n axis all right now with this
uh little recap or perhaps
uh a clear cut discussion of the direct
of the orientations of qn and mns we are
now in a position to
to try to interpret this thing
okay please note that we are not going
to derive anything related to this
rather we are going to try to interpret
this so please keep an open mind here
okay so let me go to the next
page and what i'll do is uh
i will consider uh not
one element rather two elements and you
will see
uh eventually uh what the benefit of
that
is okay there's a little trick here it
is this
trick okay this this particular trick of
considering
two elements and eventually you'll see
that we'll have to consider a third
element also
okay so that is where the trick is and
it is this trick which was actually
uh giving a challenge to the early
researchers
who investigated uh this theory
so
so you understand that
this is the positive sense of
s this is n
and this here
this here is z
okay now for this particular
element we will end up
with
a moment m n s which is in this
particular fashion
so this is our mns
now you understand that
uh
so maybe i just
so this distance here this is delta s
okay so
maybe i should have been a little bit
more forsightful with
the use of the space here but no matter
i'll just adjust it
okay so this is
delta s this also is delta s
so both of them have the same length of
delta s
okay next what i'm what we are going to
say
is that this here
is also going to have a moment but
this moment okay so this moment
it will be so this one here
will be in this fashion m n s plus delta
m s del s delta s
okay so it is in the same fashion that
we are writing this
uh so you can draw an analogy of what we
did
of what we used to do during our
undergraduate mechanics of solids
classes
so suppose you take a little element
like this
and on this side you write this as sigma
xx
and on this side you write this as sigma
xx plus
del sigma xx del x then delta x
where this length is delta x
so it is in this fashion that i want you
to interpret
these two moments okay now the uh now
as soon as we have these things in our
hand what we are going to interpret this
m s is so you see this is like a couple
this is like a couple which is uh being
generated
by uh by a sort of force
uh which is
in this fashion okay so you can
understand that if you have
a force like this
m and s divided by delta s
and you think of it uh
in this fashion that
[Music]
this is a force here and this is a force
here so these two forces together
will generate this couple so if you if
you consider these white arrows
uh they are of magnitude
mns by delta s okay so they are
mns by delta s and it makes sense
because in order to find the magnitude
of the couple which is associated with
these forces
which are each of magnitude m and s by
delta s you just have to multiply the
length between them the perpendicular
distance between them
which is nothing but delta s so the
moment which is or the or the value of
the couple or the magnitude of the
couple
which is associated with these white
colored forces
that is m s by delta s being the
magnitude of the force
multiplied by the distance between them
which is delta s so the effective thing
is actually m and s which is what we
started out from
so in a similar fashion this particular
thing
will also have a corresponding force
associated with it
and please be very very careful with the
direction of the arrows that we are
using here
okay so we are using these arrows in
such a fashion
that the couple that is generated due to
these white colored forces is indeed
going to have this kind of a
clockwise sense all right
so this particular force
this is going to have the magnitude
m s plus delta m s
del s delta s which is exactly what i
have written here
but the whole thing divided by delta s
okay so each of these forces these white
colored forces
for this second element that is going to
have this magnitude
all right now comes the final trick
that final trick is to consider
a third element um
which is
starting halfway from this first element
and ending
halfway into the second element so that
overall this particular distance
this particular distance
that is also delta s
so why are we doing this we are doing
this so that we can actually concentrate
on uh on the midpoint of this element
so somewhere here and we are going to
consider
the actual uh shear force per unit
length
that would be considered at this point
and that would be so
[Music]
so this is the shear force per unit
length
arising due to this sigma nz
so you will have so if you just focus
your attention on this
middle element this third element that
we have drawn and maybe it will be
useful if i just isolate it out here
[Music]
what we are doing is if you forget about
everything else
and i ask you that what is the shear
force
per unit length considering this point
i'm sure all of you will be easily able
to answer that this is qn
arising due to the sigma mz now
because we are considering this third
element in this particular fashion
where the effect of the moments
associated with the
sigma ns is also there
we have to recognize the fact that we
already have
a contribution from the
from the force like entities which we
have generated
by a reinterpretation of the mns
and this particular moment okay
so all in all the kind of
effective force per unit length okay
four spinning length that will have for
this third element that is going to be
in this way so we have a contribution
from qn
directly from here we'll also have a
contribution from this white colored
force
this white force has the has this thing
so let me draw that in white and please
note that
this orientation and this orientation is
the same which is why this is
white in color
i'm just repeating whatever i had
written down here
all right and
we'll also have to write down the
contribution from this but please note
that this has the opposite sense of this
okay so
there's a negative here and
let us not forget that the magnitude of
that force is this m minus delta s
by delta s
now if you just simplify this you will
see that this uh
and they should not be a delta here this
delta is wrong
so you will see that in the next step i
just write this down
this is nothing but q n plus
del m s
del s because this delta as this delta s
cancels and this
m n s by delta s cancels with this m s
by delta s
so it is in this fashion that we are
interpreting
the effective force uh along the z
direction
for uh for a generic element like this
okay so it's a little bit
convoluted and you need to put in a
little bit of effort to wrap your head
around it
but the moral of the whole story here
is to note that had you just considered
the contribution
from the sigma nz then you would have
completely discounted
the contribution from the mns
that is the contribution from the sigma
ns
which is also contributing in the
vertical direction
effectively okay so so of course
originally the sigma
ns is contributing uh
shear forces in the s direction there is
no doubt about it that's a horizontal
shear component but through the
generation
of this moment and the interpretation of
this movement in terms of this couple
we are seeing that it is effectively
contributing
in the vertical direction also so
uh unless we do this kind of
kind of a uh of an interpretation we
will completely miss that contribution
and it is going to be wrong okay so this
is
uh rather important and this is how you
need to
interpret the effective shear force okay
so the effective shear force is
basically
the force or the force per unit length
uh in the
z direction okay which takes into
account
the contributions from the various
shears
so on that note i'll end this video
thank you very much